we you know we do on this show we do
like i like uh
i love your comedy because you're so dry
it's really funny it's really funny yeah
that's what i meant
and you go for it you're modest yeah
very modest humble uh so we were talking
about if you'd be willing you want to do
uh i love prank calls not me too and you
are the two the best so we were looking
for you know if you have an idea then
i'm well before you even go any further
do you do stuff for yourself like when
you're calling somebody do you like
do a prank call like you'll turn it into
a prank call
because you're calling for a hotel
resume they don't have one
i know you people that do that but
i will just go off on a tangent you know
like you don't you don't have any rooms
what about your room can i sleep in your
room and they'll stay on the phone you
know
you've talked about this this has been
him like now it's for a reason now since
we have the podcast he plays him on here
but this is my whole life he's been
doing this i'm sure he's like the
original prankster it's always just for
him howie this is my favorite just for
me one i go to palm springs i'm doing a
corporate gig i'm doing it there's
another there's an improv group that's
also hired for the entertainment and
then there's the one of the three tenor
irish tenor singers there one of them
one of them the guy who has
wooden legs
and i had to leave it's already a joke i
had to leave for a day and i fly back
and frank sinatra's old driver picks me
up at the airport he's hired by the
company
and he picks me up he goes
miss neil i just want to tell you i'm a
huge fan i'm a huge fan of i've you know
grown grown up with you and all right
you know i listen to you all the time
and um
are the other guys here
and i'm thinking he's thinking about the
improv group i said yeah yeah they're
all there they're all there he goes and
i just i love i love all the classics
you know the classics and i'm thinking
oh this guy's old school he likes snl
the old sketches you know and then he
goes up then he's he takes it he goes
are you now are you originally from
ireland
and now i realize he thinks i'm one of
the three tenors the irish singers he's
a huge fan yeah he's a huge fan he knows
exactly what it looks like
and so i sit there i say no no i'm not
i'm i know my grandfather's from ireland
he goes oh okay okay okay
and then about 10 seconds later i'm in
the back seat right i can see him in the
mirror and i go
oh
danny boy
the pipes the
big smile on his face he couldn't
believe one of the irish tenors was
singing in his car i did it for me it
was just for me i love that but i would
have been like deafening and not stopped
like you would have yes that's the
difference between you and yeah you did
the funny joke i would just take it too
far yeah i would take the 20 minutes of
going
daddy
does that sound right to you does that
sound right to you
i won't stop now
but i would do that just annoying i love
annoying i find annoying more than uh
annoying to the nth degree though yes
but that's what annie kaufman kind of
issue i love that see to me it's it's
funny yeah and then it's not funny and
then it's anger and then it's funny
again funny than ever yes you have to
make it through that valley of hell
you have to be willing to lose a few
people in the audience
sometimes andy would lose everybody oh i
know reading the great gatsby you were
probably there many ways there i was
there too i was there the night the
evening at the improv where he did the
boil thing yeah yeah yeah you want
people to squeeze his boil he added a
boil on his neck he offered anybody from
the audience to come up and squeeze the
boil on his neck it's disgusting i have
his tony clifton noses here
really bob zumuda called me once he was
his partner yeah who played tony clifton
sometimes right
and asked me if i would referee one of
his fights the wrestling things with
annie kaufman at the comedy store yeah
but i had a gig somewhere i used to
watch those i used to go to wrestling
[Music]